BRINGS MARK GIORDANO BACK TO HIS
CENTRE, WORKS THE PUCK,UGH THE E
CALGARY FLAMES.
YOU CAN SEE THE INITIAL SHOT
LARSSON IS THERE.TCH HOW WIDE ON
WORKING THE PUCK INTO THE
TALK IN THE OFF-SEASON OF HOWAG
FIRST 11.75 SHOTS
FROM THEIR DEFENCE PER GAME ON
THAT EIGHT-GAME
JOHNNY GAUDREAU WALKS IT ACROSS.
TRYING TO FEED IT BACK TO AND T
SEATTLE GOALTENDER HANGS ON FOR
A WHISTLE.
>> Cassie: IT HASN'T BEEN ONE OF
THE G TAKES A BUMP.
ANDERSSON
SAVE AS VINCE DUNN SNEAKING IN
LET'S ONE GO.
WHERE IT TOOK ME. HAVE OUR OWN .
NOT TO GET TOO PHILOSOPHICAL.
>> Cassie: NO, AND JUST A AND
JUST IN TIME.
SHOOTS, GRUBAUER, SAVE, REBOUNDE
THAT INITIAL SAVE
GOT AWAY FROM DUNN.ICING CALL O.
TO BE A VERSATILE PLAYER AND EAK
PROBABLY BE MOVED UP AND DOWN
THISTHER
END.
>> Cassie: AND THE CROWD IS
LOVING IT.
WE'LL SHOW YOU THE SAVE BY  PLA.
SO BOTH THESE GOALIES HAVE MADE
LINE BUT NO FURTHER.
LONG SHOT 6'5".
PERIOD THREE IS UNDER WAY, AND
THOWN
BY LARSSON! GOALTENDER THERE.
JUST A SUBTLE
S LINE
WAS ACTUALLY OUT ON THE ICE AND
WAS EXPECTED MISSED GOING BACK
UNDERNEATH GRUBAUER.
SOMEHOW THAT STAYED OUT.
THTH OF YOUR T,
MANGIAPANE'S IN FRONT, TRIES A
SHOT UP HIGH, GRUBAUER MAKES TH
STOP, GRUBAUER KEEPS IT
BACKLUND WITH THE TIP, GRUBAUER
PEEK, HAS IT UNDER HIS
ARM, ABLE TO FREEZE THE
THAT McCANN BREAKS HIS STICK,
BUT IT WAS A SHOOTLE G